Why were you suicidal?
It's because going through
very big states in life,
but I can go so deep
that I don't find a way out.
I know you right now.
You got a lot to give.
-Can you feel me?
-I do.
You and I are gonna make a deal.
I'm gonna show you
what to do to reshape yourself.
How is it that people
can make lasting changes in minutes?
What makes that possible?
I'll have one camera on Tony
and one camera on the intervention,
but I don't wanna screw up
what you're doing.
The challenge is,
we never know where he's gonna go.
I'm a kid from Azusa, California,
who did not have any certainty,
but I was certain of one thing.
My insatiable hunger
to end suffering for any human I can.
-Good morning.
"Date With Destiny"
is my very favorite event.
Just because it covers the controlling
force that controls everything.
-They're ready for you.
-Do you get nervous?
-Is there stage fright?
-No, there's no stage fright.
My job is to dominate the problem
and bring out what's really strong.
-Childhood beating.
-Constant pain.
-Sexual abuse.
-Father abandoned him.
Mother was murdered by stepfather.
Held hostage for three days.
Are you ever concerned about
giving the wrong piece of advice?
I'm looking for what's real,
and when I find it, I take that bait
and take it all the way to the soul.
Our entire life changes in a moment.
Who gets that? Say "aye."
Aye!
Problems are what make us grow.
Authenticity will lead to a rich life.
Life is always happening for us,
not to us.
Everybody's got their thing,
and this is my thing.
You haven't deserved any of it.
But out of pain,
comes unbelievable strength.
You're incredible.
-What did you see in their eyes?
-Love.
How do we get love
from every kind of person?
We do the right thing?
I just really believe
people's love and caring.
If they led with that,
they'd find the way.
One, two, three!
Make the sound of who you are!
Make your life a masterpiece,
my dear friends.